[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Traffic signal
poles must be strong enough
to bear the weight of
road signs, street lights,
and, of course, traffic signals.
The poles are also
built to withstand
extreme weather conditions,
such as high winds
and heavy snow accumulation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Traffic signal poles are
made of high strength steel.
Years of weather exposure
can cause corrosion,
so the poles are galvanized
on both sides for protection.
Each pole has a welded
plate to connect
it to a perpendicular pole.
The poles are made out
of these steel sheets.
The steel arrives at the
factory in one large roll.
They use a decoiler to unwind
the sheet and flatten it out.
Then, as shear cuts it
to the correct length.
A computer-guided plasma
cutter marks short lines
on both ends of the sheet.
These lines indicate where
to bend the flat sheet
to form a round pole.
The machine cuts the sheet
into a rectangular shape
or a trapezoid shape, if the
pole will taper at the top.
Workers number of the
machine lines with chalk,
giving lines directly opposite
of each other the same number.
Then, they transfer the
sheet to a bending machine
called a press break.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The press break bends the
sheet along the marked line
to a pre-programmed angle.
Workers use a digital
measuring device
to make sure the first
bend is accurate.
If it is, they continue
bending along the remainder
of the lines, transforming
the flat sheet
into a multisided round pole.
Now, the poll moves
to a welding station
where hydraulic rollers apply
pressure from both sides.
This forces the
edges of the sheet
together so that a
welding head can fuse
the seam with molten steel.
At the same time, the head
deposits a granular powder
called flux, which prevents
air from penetrating the weld
and weakening it.
Workers place the pole
in a hydraulic press,
so it doesn't warp as the
seam weld cools and shrinks.
Next, a computer-guided plasma
machine cuts a connection
played out of thick steel.
The machine also drills
holes for the high strength
bolts needed to attach the plate
to the traffic signal pole.
Workers center the
connection plate on support
plates they've already
welded to the pole.
Then, they weld
everything in place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next, workers weld a base plate
to the bottom of the pole.
It has holes for
the anchor bolts
which are used for securing the
traffic signal to the street.
Workers inspect the welds
with a testing device.
It uses an electric current
to magnetically draw colored
powder into any defective area.
The factory ships
the finished poles
to a galvanizing plant
where they're dipped
in a series of wash tanks.
The plants' tanks are deep
enough to fully submerge
the poles so they can treat
both the inner and outer surface
at the same time.
Now, the poles go into
a vat of sulfuric acid.
This bath dissolves the
more stubborn contaminants
that washing can't remove.
The next tank contains
a chemical that weakens
the surface of the poles.
This allows the galvanizing
metal to penetrate the steel
rather than sit on the surface.
The final tank
contains molten zinc.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As the poles bathe in
the 842 degree zinc,
workers in fire
protection suits skim
the surface to remove iron oxide
and ash that floats to the top.
This keeps the freshly
galvanized surface
clean as the poles are
hoisted out of the tank
and set aside to cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Because they're galvanized
rather than painted,
these polls are able
to support traffic
lights, signs, and street
lamps for 40 years or more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]